in this lesson we're going to talk about
the rules of exponents so this is
definitely something important you want
to know for the new and revised s80
let's go over the properties and the
rules of exponents here and then we'll
get into some examples so first of all
okay just a quick review here when you
multiply and you have the same base okay
this bottom number what do you do to the
exponents you add them okay when you
have a power raised to another power an
exponent raised to another exponent
that's when you multiply the exponents
you keep the base the same though and
then here when you divide you subtract
the exponents you make sure you take the
numerator exponent minus the denominator
exponent right and if you get a negative
exponent what that tells you to do is to
take the reciprocal so you move this to
the other side of the fraction bar and
make it a positive exponent and then of
course anything to the zero power equals
1 so these are some of the key rules of
exponents you want to remember and
revise and not review ok so here in the
example 1 it says that 18 X minus 4
equals 10 what is the value of e squared
to the 3 X all divided by 2 to the 4th
ok so what is that value and we can have
some options here with got 08 to the
10th 2 2 the tenth or 4 squared so go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
do that one on your own and we'll go
through it together so the first thing
that I'm going to do here is I'm going
to look at this and I'm going to realize
that eat is really like 2 cubed right
because 2 times 2 times 2 to 3 times and
then that's actually being squared see
right here and the whole thing is being
raised to the 3x power ok all divided by
2 to the fourth now when you have a
power to a power you multiply right so
this is going to be 2 to the sixth power
all raised to the 3x over 2 to the
fourth and again we have a power to
power so we multiply so that's going to
be 2 to the 18 x all over 2 to the
fourth and then when we divide and we
have the same base we subtract the
exponents so it's going to be 18 X minus
4 and I notice i just kept the base of
thing you keep that base to your just
subtracting the exponents but now
remember what they told us in the
beginning is that 18x minus 4 equals 10
so I can replace this with what it
equals which is 10 so this is going to
be 2 to the tenth power so the best
answer here is
see now notice the key here was to get
the basis to view the same eight and to
both have two in common right because it
eight was two cubed and then that
allowed us to use the rules of exponents
because we had the same base let's go to
example number two so here it says if X
to the to see power all the Vitamix to
the 4d power and then that whole
quantity squared equals x to the eighth
and then it says v is equal to three
find the value of C okay so this one
we're on our own it's a free response so
here it says if d is 3 i'm going to put
three right in place of d so let's do
that that's x to this to see all over x
to the 4 times 3 remember when the right
next to each other like that that means
multiplication and then that's all
raised to the second power equals x to
the eighth okay now when you divide what
do you do to the exponents when you have
the same base you subtract right so
that's going to be X to the 2c minus 12
all squared equals x to the eighth and
then when you have a power raised to
another power what do you do you
multiply but in this case when we're
multiplying we have to distribute right
because this whole thing times 2 which
gives you access to the 4 C minus 24
equals x to the eighth and then what we
have is what's called the Wonder one
property for exponents and that's that
if you have the same base the exponents
must be equal so we have four C minus 24
must equal 8 in order for this equation
to be true so let's just solve that
we're going to add 24 to both sides okay
we get 4 C equals 32 divided everything
by 4 and you can see that c is equal to
8 and that's what they want is fine so
again review the properties of exponents
if you need to go over these examples
again if you need to and I look forward
to seeing the next lesson